how to build on the overthrow of
dictatorship in the Arab world with the
uprising in Syria worsening day by day
and sectarian splits threatening
hard-won Democratic gains across the
region with an eye on the Kiro the media
and women played in the Arab Spring emmy
peace gathered journalists and experts
to Parliament to share experiences and
brainstorm solutions Egyptian women went
to it's a hurry square went to the first
day of devolution before and after who
is a shoulder by shoulder by men and yet
when you go to the political life its
minimum sometimes they are cursed they
are criticized they are pressured either
by the family by their husbands by the
community I believe the European Union
is is able to do more than they are
doing at the moment to make a pressure
on all parties to reach peace settlement
they have to ease the life of the people
because they become less violent in both
side in Israeli sign and Palestinian
side the conference took place as
Britain and France confirmed the use of
chemical weapons in Syria raising cause
more EU action in the search for peace
it's a very very dangerous development
but it's one of many dangerous
developments in Syria we have to look to
High Representative Ashton to take much
more of a leadership position in making
a comprehensive plan for Syria and for
the region because the spillover effects
into countries like Lebanon Jordan and
even Turkey are huge protests against
the government are already flaring
across Turkey according to one MEP it
all underlines the need to strengthen
democracy with a free media as a key
tool democracy how to say is not yet
looted I think they are far away from
democracy and therefore they are far
away from free media so in which way we
can help it is very difficult but we
should not give up because we do it all
over Europe and we should also stick to
the neighborhood because it's our
neighborhood the Arab Spring countries
and the EU recognize their mutual
dependence for growth and stability they
also recognize there's a long way to
travel to achieve that